nick matt hancock in the last few
minutes has resigned
as health and social care secretary he's
written to the prime minister
boris johnson who has returned with a
letter as his protocol
and those have just been released to the
media and circulated in the last
few minutes i can read to you from the
letter that matt hancock
has sent to boris johnson he says i'm
writing to resign as secretary of state
for health and social care we have
worked so hard as a country to fight the
pandemic the last thing i would want is
for my private life
to distract attention from the
single-minded focus that is leading us
out of this crisis
i want to reiterate my apology for
breaking the guidance and apologize to
my family
and loved ones for putting them through
this i also need to be with my children
at this time so matt hancock saying
that he does not want what has been
going on in his private life with gina
colladangelo
to get in the way of what is happening
um
with the pandemic and after a day or two
of revelations deciding uh that um he
should
step down from that important role no
indication
necessarily whether there was any
pressure put on him from number 10
from this letter it does sound like this
is a decision that he seems to have
reached
on his own uh he goes on in this letter
to boris johnson to say
we owe it to the people who have
sacrificed so much in this pandemic
to be honest when we have let them down
as i have done by breaching the guidance
the nhs is the best gift
a nation has ever given itself and the
dedication and courage
of the nhs staff and the ceaseless work
of the officials in the department is
something we should all be proud of
we didn't get every decision right but i
know people understand how hard it is
to deal with the unknown making the
difficult trade-offs between freedom
prosperity and the health that we have
faced so
matt hancock seemingly reaching the
decision that given everything that has
happened in the last
day or two and set against the context
of being
really one of the probably two or three
main government faces and spokespeople
for this pandemic
after the prime minister the person who
has appeared in those press conferences
most frequently and is frequently asking
the public to abide by rules
we have seen him talking about not
giving into temptation
and not letting rules slip even for a
moment
matt hancock has clearly decided that
given
he has been found to be breaching that
guidance and in this part of the letter
that we've got through so far he only
admits to breaching the guidance which
is
crucial because lawyers have said that
actually he may well have breached the
law in terms of
those pictures that were circulating
with that department of health and
social care
aid he has decided that actually clearly
he does not feel
that he is the person that can stay in
place to deliver that message and feels
that his presence
crucially as the health secretary could
undermine and would undermine the
government's effort
to fight that pandemic this pandemic
that we
are still living through given yes rules
are falling um
away and are not as tighter as say last
march april may
when these previous scandals involving
rule breaking in the government
but we are still in a crucial point and
he clearly feels that his presence there
is no longer helpful
uh to the government i mean boris
johnson had given him
uh this defense like he had done for
previous ministers but
matt hancock's position really has been
looking
increasingly untenable yeah and i think
it's notable that clearly this is a
resignation and all we can gather so far
is this has come
off matt hancock's own back that he
hasn't been
uh forced out by downing street of
course boris johnson
yesterday through his spokesperson made
it very clear that he had accepted matt
hancock's
apology and he now considered the case
closed since then there has not been any
new significant revelations what we have
had is video
of the encounter of matt hancock um and
gina
collidangelo in those offices of
government in the department of health
and social care but what we have started
to see
some mps coming forward
rob we we um appear to have a statement
uh on a video from uh matt
hancock which he has posted on twitter i
wonder if he can just have a look at
that now
i've been to see the prime minister to
resign as
secretary of state for health and social
care
i understand the enormous sacrifices
that
everybody in this country has made that
you have made
and those of us who make these
rules have got to stick by them and
that's why
i've got to resign i want to thank
people
for their incredible sacrifices and what
they've done
everybody working in the nhs across
social care
everyone involved in the in the vaccine
program
and frankly everybody in this country
who has
risen to the challenges that we've seen
over this past 18 months
i'm very proud of what we've done to
protect the nhs
at the peak to deliver that vaccine
rollout
for one of the fastest in the world and
i look forward to
supporting the government and the prime
minister from the back benches
to make sure that we can get out of this
pandemic
we're so close to the end and then
build back better so that this country
can fulfill
its potential which is so great
and i will do that with all of my heart
well that's matt hancock there the
health secretary who as we
know has just resigned and you can see
some of his letter there to boris
johnson's read you
a little bit of it i am writing to
resign
as secretary of state for health and
social care
we have worked so hard as a country to
fight the pandemic the last thing i
would want is for my private life
to distract attention from as he puts it
the single-minded focus that is
leading us out of this crisis i want to
reiterate my apology the breaking
the guidance and apologize to my family
and loved ones
for putting them through this i also
need to be with my children at this
time we owe it to people who have
sacrificed so much
in this pandemic to be honest when we
have let them down
as i have done by breaching the guidance
the nhs is the best gift a nation has
ever given itself and the dedication
and courage of the nhs staff and the
ceaseless work of the officials in the
department is something
we should all be proud of we didn't get
every decision
right but i know people understand how
hard it is to deal with the unknown
making the difficult trade-offs between
freedom prosperity and health
that we have faced and i'm so proud he
says that britain avoided the
catastrophe in his words of an
overwhelmed nhs and that through
foresight and brilliant science we have
led the world in the vaccination effort
so we stand
on the brink of a return to normality
a little bit more the reforms we have
started in the health system will ensure
it continues to provide even better care
for people in years to come we are
building a better nhs which makes
smarter use of technology and data
forming a new
uk health security agency that's led of
course by
jenny harris delivering positive changes
to mental health care
and we'll fix the problems in social
care once
and for all he does go on many times i
stood at the podium in downing street
and thanked the team my own team the nhs
the volunteers the armed services
our pharmacist gp's the pharmaceutical
industry and the whole british public
who have made such sacrifices to help
others those thanks
matt hancock says are heartfelt and
sincere
and so i must resign uh he does go on
but that's uh the nub of it
uh quite a long resignation letter uh to
the
prime minister there you can see uh rob
powell
joins me again from westminster so these
dramatic developments
confirmed in the past few minutes and
we've actually seen this video footage
uh twitter of matt hancock have to say
look pretty wounded
yeah i i think uh it's undoubtedly um
probably not been a
a an easy day or two um for matt hancock
i think he
clearly has been doing a lot of thinking
what we have seen
today the first conservative mps coming
out suggesting that he should consider
his position
i think behind the scenes a lot of tory
mps as well had decided
that maybe that was the best course of
action
i think there was conspicuous silence in
terms of support from tory mps very few
people on tv and radio
few people going on to twitter to make
their support known as happened
with dominic cummings and pretty betel
where there was support for them that
didn't seem to be there
for matt hancock now we have also had a
letter
that boris johnson has sent back to matt
hancock
as is usual there is usually an exchange
of letters that is published
in that letter boris johnson says that
matt hancock should be um immensely
proud of what he has done as secretary
of state
um for health and social care uh he also
says he is sorry to receive
um his um resignation uh letter he talks
about
uh what was achieved throughout the
pandemic and also talks about
some of the other reforms that have gone
on in the nhs and will be going on in
the nhs because
if matt hancock was to stay in position
it would not just be the task
of leading us fully out of this pandemic
that would be in his in tray
there is a lot of nhs reform that is on
the plate um as well not to mention
the promised social care reform so it
really would have been continued to be
one of the highest profile roles in
cabinet but in boris johnson's letter
crucially
um as well he also uh talks
um about how he believes that matt
hancock's contribution to public service
um is far from over and i think talking
to some conservative mps
today and conservative members that are
more supportive
of matt hancock in general i i think
part of the
reasoning they had for suggesting that
matt hancock should step down and should
resign now
is that it might mean that at some point
in the future he is in a better place to
save his overall
political career and further down the
line maybe he can make a comeback
to politics on the front line i think
clearly that is unlikely
um in the short term and now the
question clearly for boris johnson
is what he does in terms of filling that
vacancy
as health secretary someone that will
have to deal
with the rest of the pandemic but also
getting the nhs
back um on on more of an even keel in
terms of catching up with missed
operations and delayed
um appointments and treatments that have
gone missed over the last
15 months and then pushing forward with
the overall reforms they want to get
through
and also figuring out a plan for social
care um
as well i think it begs the question
that if a long rumored reshuffle
uh is on the cards uh now a wider
reshuffle or whether he will look to
just bring someone in
potentially from another cabinet post
and then backfill behind that
um as well clearly some of the names
that have been linked with health
secretary in the past have been people
like michael gove people
who have uh got more of a record uh of
getting things done
in departments but this uh will have to
be a very carefully
thought out choice in terms of for matt
hancock what this means politically for
his career he has seen
something of a continuing ascension over
the last
few years he's someone that started off
as a special adviser to the former
chancellor george osborne although he
was in the shadow cabinet
when matt hancock was working for him he
became chief of staff and then went on
to become
mp an mp in suffolk he held a number of
junior minister roles business minister
roles before he became
culture secretary i think one of the
youngest cabinet ministers and culture
secretaries
appointed that was under theresa may and
then
funnily enough his move up to health
was at least partly as a result of boris
johnson's resignation from the foreign
office boris johnson resigned
over theresa may's brexit plan that saw
long-term health secretary jeremy hunt
moved into the foreign office and matt
hancock moved into health
behind him he was one of the very few
cabinet ministers
who stayed in post when boris johnson
took over
from theresa may i think he was seen as
someone that
had achieved maybe the rare um
occurrence of a rare achievement
of keeping nhs winter pressures and um
the usual pre-covered winter pressures
that the nhs had
largely out of the headline so i think
he impressed on that and that is why
he managed to keep the job but of course
like the rest of the country
and the rest of the cabinet he can't
have seen what was coming
um in terms of the pandemic and covert
19 and all of a sudden
he has been thrust into probably the
most high profile
political position in the country behind
boris johnson we frequently see him
um hosting those downing street press
conferences appealing to the public
not to give in to keep going with the
rules
and in that resignation letter he talks
about
uh the thanks that he's given the public
and everyone else for abiding by the
rules to get the country through the
pandemic
and says that those thanks were sincere
and as a result that is why he believes
he has to resign so clearly matt hancock
had been reflecting on the fact uh
that it seemed increasingly difficult to
reconcile
what he had the message he had been
putting out in terms of abiding by
restrictions and doing your duty
uh with what he was photographed doing
around
a month and a half ago uh i imagine as
well
it would have hit hard hearing from uh
some of the bereaved families of people
who had lost relatives to covert 19
we've been speaking
um to one person who lost a husband
today
who talked really about how whilst
everyone else was abiding by the rules
whilst they weren't hugging loved ones
weren't hugging people at funerals
matt hancock seemed to think that those
rules didn't apply
um to him so i i think the fact that
those people felt let down as well
may be weighed heavily on the mind of
the health secretary which is why he has
now made this decision
uh that he can no longer remain in post